and I've actually been doing research
recently with the latest developments in
stem cell exosomes these types of things
I think it's going to lead to a a real
revolution in health care and
particularly in longevity you know it's
kind of the Wild West in the US the uh
FDA is somewhat controlling with it
there is a lot of innovation being done
you get every joint in the body injected
as well as cosmetic and sexual
injections the thing we're going to be
finding in the very near future is an
incredible overlap between these more
ancient Sciences like the DST knowledge
of internal Alchemy and the human
internal energy system with the
meridians acupuncture points Etc and
what we found through empirical
discoveries having to do with the
activation and direction of stem cells
exosomes injection of PRP and things of
that kind when you see what's actually
happening with people who are getting
some of these treatments just absolutely
revolutionary